Speaker 1: All right. You knew it was
coming today. You knew that today. I
was going to tell you that Mypillow CEO and
founder Mike Lindell, known to us as Pillow,
the guy who wants to sue the machines.
Speaker 3: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 1: His phone has been seized by the FBI
at a Hardees drive thru. You really cannot
write this stuff. This is unbelievable. You
play with fire, you might end up getting burned.
Daily Beast reports. Mike Lindell Feds seized
my cell phone at Hardee's. They took my phone.
The FBI did. Look at this video. This is pillow
himself explaining the situation last night.
Speaker 3: To the FBI. You're going to hear
this and you probably already hear it in the
news. The FBI came after me and took my phone
and surrounded me at a Hardee's and took my
phone. I ran all my business. Everything went
on. And they could have just what we've done
is weaponize the FBI. It's disgusting. I don't
have a computer. Everything I do a cell phone,
everything was on there and the Bible. And they
told me not to tell anybody who's in order not
to. Don't tell anybody, okay. How old I am. So.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So there it is. Mike Pillow
raided by the FBI. Here he is on the Lindell
report, which is hosted by someone else
explaining exactly what happened. And again,
you cannot write this stuff. And pillows ability
to destroy his own reputation, his own financial
future over nonsense is really incredible.
Speaker 3: And we go through a Hardee's
drive thru. We pull round the back and we're
just about gone through. We pulled through the
drive through to take the order. We pull up and
she says, pull ahead, you know, because they had
to make the order. Tarver wasn't done. We pull
ahead and a car comes perpendicular and park a
little ways in front of us tonight. And I've been
around the block, and I said to my buddy, I said,
That's either a bad guy or it's it's FBI.
Speaker 1: Which I guess now is one in the same
for these guys. So anyway, as you know, I have not
been to a fast food restaurant in 20 years other
than that emergency Starbucks stop a few weeks
ago that I told you about. I have to imagine
that even within the fast food space, Hardee's
is not exactly the best. But I did look it up.
I found that Hardee's has a hand-breaded chicken
biscuit, which sounds pretty good, but let's put
that aside for now. Pillow reportedly worth $300
million at a Hardee's and gets his phone seized by
the FBI. Now, I think it's important to mention.
Mike Pillow says that this happened. We don't at
this point have independent confirmation that the
FBI actually seized his phone. But let's assume
that he is telling the truth about it and not
making this up whole cloth. And on that basis,
Donald Trump is absolutely furious. Donald Trump
Posting to Truth Essential Breaking News. Mike
Lindell The pillow guy was just raided by
the FBI. We are now officially living in a
weaponized police, state rigged elections and
all our country is a laughing stock. All over
the world. The majesty of the United States
is gone. Can't let this happen. Take back
America. And Pillow is furious about other
things as well. Let's talk about that next.